Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought
to you by four sigmatic.
You might remember four sigmatic
for their mushroom coffee,
which was created by those
clever finish founders.
And when I first mentioned
that coffee on this podcast,
the product sold out in less than a week.
It lights you up like a Christmas tree,
which can be really useful.
However,
recently I've been testing the opposite
side of the spectrum of new product and
that is their Reishi mushroom elixir
to help me end my day to get to sleep.
As you guys may know,
longtime listeners,
at least I struggled with insomnia for
decades. I have a largely fixed that,
but still shutting off my monkey
brain has never been easy,
still isn't easy very
often and I found Reishi,
which had been fascinated by for
a few years now, has been very,
very effective and calming
their old formula. However,
four sigmatic old formula included
Stevia and I like to avoid sweeteners,
all sweeteners for a host of reasons,
and I then just ping them and asked,
hey guys,
I would love to experiment with
this and maybe actually suggested,
but I'd like a version without
sweeteners if he'd be open to it.
If too much of a headache,
don't worry.
And they are always game
for experimentation.
So they created a special custom version
without the Stevia, without sweeteners.
Now it is part of my nightly routine.
Their ratio looks comes
in single serving packets,
which are perfect for travel and in fact
I'm about to leave the country right
now and I have a packet in front of me
that's just going to sit in the end of my
carry on bag.
You only need hot water and it mixes very,
very easily.
Here's some recommended copy
that they put in the read,
so I'm going to read it and then I'll
give you my take quote, a warning.
For those in the experimental mindset,
Reishi is strong and bitter in
parentheses like any great medicine.
So if the bitterness is too much,
I recommend trying it with honey end or
nut milk such as almond milk and quote.
So I'm going to say,
no,
you should suck it up and you should drink
the tea because it's not that bitter.
And maybe should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
younguns. When they say
Boone, unsure. Cool.
Which means you're not able to eat
bitterness. Bitter is in many cases,
an indication of things that help
liver detoxification and so on.
Not saying that's the case here,
but I've tested this ratio
lecture on family members,
on friends. Everybody has liked it. It's
a little bit earthy. It's not that hard.
So I would just say suck it up and no,
don't put in honey or milk or any of
that shit. Just drink the goddamn tea.
It's delicious, I think. Right? If
you like poo air, that kind of stuff,
that type of tea, you're going
to dig it. So just try it. Okay.
Back to then my read. If you'd like
to naturally improve your sleep,
both onset and quality,
I think naturally you might just
enjoy this reishi elixir without any
sweeteners. It has organic, Reishi
extract, organic fueled, mint extract,
organic rose hips extract, organic
Tulsi extract. And that's it.
No fancy stuff, no artificial watching
McCall at anything. So check it out.
Go to foursigmatic.com forward slash
and Ferris and get 20% off this special
batch. I don't know if they're gonna
be making much more of this, uh,
it since it was made specifically for
you guys to do me a favor and try it out
so that they continue to be
open to experimenting with
me to create products for
you guys. Specifically, check it out.
Four sigmatic, that's Flur, s, I,
g m, a t, I c.com forward
slash Ferris, F, e R, r,
I s,
s and get 20% off the special batch and a,
you must use the code of Ferris to
receive a discount. F, e R, R, I s.
S.
So again,
going to foursigmatic.com forward slash
Ferris and then use code Ferris for 20%
off of this rare exclusive limited run
of Reishi mushroom elixir for nighttime
routines with out any sweeteners.
Enjoy.
This episode is brought to you
by Athletic Greens every year.
Of course people look for
new ways to become healthier,
to take their fitness and so
on to the next level. For me,
step number one is having some
form of nutritional insurance.
That's how I would look at it and the
nutritional insurance needs to make sure
all of my basic needs are met.
All the boxes checked regardless of
travel schedule, missed meals and so on.
They're going to be times in the new
year when your diet and exercise will get
interrupted. Life will interrupt it in
during those times. You want a safety net.
I get asked all the time, if you could
only use one supplement, what would it be?
And my answer is
inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one
nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to
ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day.
As listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can receive 30% off of your first
order by visiting Athletic greens.com
forward slash Tim.
That is a great deal on one of my favorite
products and it covers my basis each
day. It is part of my routine and it
leaves me with less to worry about if,
for instance, I have to skip a meal
or just can't get a high quality meal,
so check it out.
Go to athleticgreens.com forward
slash Tim and learn all about it.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
boys and girls.
And welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss Show where it is always my job,
each and every episode to interview
world performers and experts,
leaders in all fields,
and that ranges from amazing athletes to
military personnel to chess prodigies,
to famous investors. And
beyond. In this episode,
we're going to set a new
podcast record for this show,
at least with five different guests.
These are people that I have
interviewed remotely and uh,
this episode today features Adam Robinson,
Debbie Millman,
Neil Strauss, Scott Belsky,
and Veronica Belmont.
These are all people who are,
I consider the best at what they do or
at least one of the best in the world at
the many things that they do. And that
of course includes investing, chess,
graphic design, writing
tech, and much, much more.
This particular round table discussion
covers topics pose to all of them,
questions posed to all of them,
including best investments,
what are the best investments
they've ever made,
what are their favorite failures?
In other words,
failures that have led to later successes
and bad recommendations in their areas
of expertise that you should avoid.
This is a composite episode which many
of you have requested explicitly because
you wanna be able to see the patterns
and each guest offers a lot of actionable
life advice.
So without further ado,
please give a listen and I hope you
enjoy this as much as I did. Okay.
Our guest today is Adam Robinson.
You
can
find
them
on
twitter@iamadamrobinsonoratrobinsonglobalstrategies.com
Adam has made a lifelong
study of outflanking and
outsmarting the competition.
He has rated chess master and has been
awarded a life master title by the United
States Chess Federation as a teenager.
He was personally mentored by Bobby
Fisher in the 18 months leading up to his
winning the world championship.
And Adam and I talked a lot about this
in our first conversation on the Tim
Ferriss show that you guys can check out.
But back to the bio.
Then in Adam's first career,
he developed a revolutionary approach to
taking standardized tests as one of the
two original cofounders
of the Princeton Review,
his paradigm breaking or category killing
as they in publishing test prep book
cracking the system.
The sat is the only test prep book
to have ever become a New York Times
bestseller. After selling his
interest in the Princeton Review,
Adam turned his attention in the early
nineties to the then emerging field of
artificial intelligence developing a
program that could analyze texts and
provide human like commentary.
He was later invited to join a well
known quant fund to develop statistical
trading models and since he's established
himself as an independent global macro
advisor to the chief investment officers
of a select group of the world's most
successful hedge funds and ultra
high net worth family offices.
What are bad recommendations that you
hear in your profession or area of
expertise?
My field is that of global finance
and virtually all have been told
when they were younger or implicitly
belief or tacitly encouraged to do so.
But the cookie cutter curriculum is a
business schools. They all attend that.
The more they understand the world,
the better their investment results.
It makes sense,
doesn't it?
The more information we acquire
an evaluate the air quotes,
better informed we become
and the better our decisions.
Accumulating information becoming better
informed is certainly an advantage in
numerous, if not most fields, but not in
the counterintuitive world of investing.
We're accumulating information can
actually hurt your investment results.
So in 1974 Paul Slovic,
a worldclass psychologist and a pure
of Nobel laureate, Daniel Kahneman,
decided to evaluate the effect of
information on decision making.
This study should be taught at every
business school in the country.
Slavic gathered eight professional course
handicappers and announced to them,
I want to see how well you predict
the winners of horse races. Now,
these handicappers were all seasoned
professionals who made their living solely
on their gambling skills,
so love it.
Told them the test would consist of
predicting 40 horse races in four
consecutive rounds in the first round.
Each gambler would be given the five
pieces of information he wanted on each
horse, which would vary from handicapper
to handicapper. One handicap,
for example,
it might want the years of experience.
The jockey has had his one
of his top five variables,
while another might not
care at all about that,
but want the fastest speed for any given
a horse that achieved in the past year
or the weight of the jockey or whatever.
Finally,
in addition to asking the handicappers
to predict the winner of each race,
he asked each one to also state how
confident he was in his prediction.
Now, as it turns out, there were an
average of 10 horses in each race,
so we would expect by blind chance,
random guessing that each handicapper
would be right 10% of the time at that,
their confidence with a blind
guests to be 10% so in round one,
let's see how they did with
just five pieces of information.
The handicappers where 17% accurate,
which is pretty good,
actually 70% better than the 10% chance
they started with given zero pieces of
information.
And interestingly,
their confidence with 19% almost exactly
as confident as they should have been.
They were 17% accurate in 19%
confident in their predictions.
Excellent calibration in round two they
were then given 10 pieces of information
in round three 20 and in
the fourth and final round,
each handicapper was given
40 pieces of information.
That's a whole lot more statistics than
the five pieces of information they each
started with.
Surprisingly,
their accuracy had flatlined at 17%
they were no more accurate with the
additional 35 pieces of information
they had. Unfortunately,
their confidence in their predictions
had nearly doubled to 31% so the
additional information made them no more
accurate but a whole lot more confident,
which would have led them to increase
the size of their bets and lose money.
As a result,
beyond a certain amount of information,
certain minimal amount,
additional information only
feeds confirmation bias.
Leaving aside the considerable costs
and delay occasioned in acquiring that
information.
The additional information we gained that
conflicts with our original assessment
or conclusion we conveniently ignore
or dismiss while the information that
confirms our original decision makes us
increasingly certain that our conclusion
was correct.
So to return to investing.
The second problem with
trying to understand the world
is that is simply far too
complex to grasp and the more dog at
our attempts to understand the world,
the more earnestly we want
to explain that's air quotes,
explain events and trends in it.
The more we become attached
to our resulting beliefs,
which are almost always
more or less mistaken,
blinding us to the financial trends that
are actually unfolding right in front
of our eyes. Worse, we think
we understand the world,
giving us a false sense of confidence
when in fact we are almost always more or
less mistaken.
You hear all the time from even the most
seasoned investors and financial expert
that this trend or that
doesn't make sense.
It doesn't make sense for the dollar keeps
going lower or it makes no sense that
stock's keep going higher.
But what's really going on when investors
say that something makes no sense is
that they have a dozen or whatever reasons
why the trend should be moving in the
opposite direction. Yet it keeps
moving in the current direction.
So they believe the trend
air quotes makes no sense,
but what makes no sense is
their model of the world.
That's what doesn't make sense.
The world always makes sense.
We just don't understand it.
In fact,
because financial trends involve human
behavior and human beliefs on a global
scale,
the most powerful trends won't make
sense until it becomes too late to profit
from them. By the time investors
formulate and understanding, again,
a false understanding that gives them
the feeling of confidence to invest.
The investment opportunity
has likely already past.
So when I hear sophisticated investors or
financial commentators say for example,
that it makes no sense how energy stocks
keep going lower and know that energy
stocks have a lot lower to go because
all those investors are on the wrong side
of the trade in denial,
probably doubling down on their
original decision to buy energy stocks.
Eventually there'll be forced to throw
in the towel and have to sell those
energy stocks.
Driving prices still lower.
What is one of the best or most
worthwhile investments you've ever made?
I've made many investments in my
life. If money of time, of energy,
of passion and emotion,
and one of the best payoffs for the
invested was learning to meditate.
I've always been driven,
excited by the world,
so my mind is continually racing at a
thousand miles per hour pursuing this
question or that creating this system
or that nonstop 24 hours a day,
365 days a year,
366 on leap years.
Now all that nonstop mental and psychic
stimulation gets exhausting of course,
and if you want to perform
optimally at anything,
you need to find a way to recover
from the stresses of that activity.
So I knew that though I should find a
way to turn off my mind and air quotes,
just relax.
Justin joy just be.
For years I had failed to find
a way. I tried everything. Yoga,
exercise.
I even tried hypnosis.
I research once the best hypnotist in New
York City as a way to somehow turn off
my hyperactive mind,
but after four attempted and usually
expensive sessions with this guy,
the hypnotist gave up saying, your mind
is too active to submit to the hypnosis.
What's the thanks a lot dark.
I told them not concealing my annoyance.
That's exactly why I had come to him.
Then about two years ago,
my best g Josh Waitzkin,
recognizing that I couldn't unwind or
disengage from my relentless analyzing the
world, especially in the financial world,
recommended that I take up meditation.
Sorry,
I said it doesn't work for me.
I can't sit still long enough for any
benefits of meditating to kick in.
So he asked, have you ever tried
heart rate variability training,
HRV training? And I said, no. What's that?
He said that you just focused on your
breathing using biofeedback to measure the
smoothness and the amplitude.
Hence the word variability
of your heart rate.
The heart not surprisingly,
registers all our realtime
emotions and stresses.
So the normal heartbeat is highly erratic
staying within a tight band around an
average.
The goal with the VI biofeedback training
is to gain control over your own heart
rate by focusing on your breathing,
making your Jagat heart rate's
smooth out like a sine curve,
and to widen its amplitude.
That sounded interesting,
but it wasn't until I reframed
meditation that I submitted a trying it.
The problem with meditation I thought
was that it wasn't practical and worse.
The time I spent meditating was Tom.
I could've spent analyzing the world,
but I eventually reframe meditation
as a way to relinquish control of my
conscious mind so that my more powerful
unconscious mind could take over and my
analysis of the world would improve.
Motivated by that reframing.
I enthusiastically adopted biofeedback,
HRV training and in a few weeks learn to
quiet my mind after just a single deep
diaphragm belly breath,
getting the ability to achieve
a zen like calm on demand.
Now,
whenever I need to detach from the world
or from the stresses of daily life and
to allow my mind arrest,
I simply get centered and inhale from my
diaphragm and I do so numerous times a
day, a minute here, a minute there,
and at least once a day I waste.
That's air quotes.
I waste a larger 15 to 20 minute
block of time meditating in this way,
but it's not wasted time.
Of course,
since the increased creativity and
productivity from these mini restorative
sessions,
it's far more valuable than the
time I spend being unproductive.
Again, air quotes while meditating,
meditation is one of the most practical,
powerful productivity enhancing tools
ever created and learning to meditate is
one of the best
investments I've ever made.
Today's guest is Debbie Millman,
one of my favorite people,
Debbie Millman at Debbie Millman
on Twitter and Instagram.
So please say hello and Debbie millman.com
she has been called one of the most
influential designers working
today by graphic design USA.
She is the founder and
host of design matters,
the world's first and longest running
podcast about design where she's
interviewed nearly 300 design luminaries
and cultural commentators including
Mossimo,
Vin Yeley and Milton Glaser.
Her artwork has been exhibited around
the world and she's designed everything
from wrapping paper to beach towels,
greeting cards to playing cards,
notebooks to tee shirts and star wars
merchandise to Global Burger King
rebrands.
She's done everything.
Debby is the president emeritus of a IGA,
one of only five women to
hold the position and the
organization's hundred year
history,
the editorial and creative director of
print magazine and the author of six
books in 2009 Debbie cofounded
alongside Steven Heller,
the world's first masters program in
branding at the school of visual arts in
New York City,
which has received international acclaim.
Debbie is brilliant.
She is one of the sweetest humans
I know Andy has taught me so,
so much including as you will learn,
busy is a decision.
So without further ado,
please enjoy the ever interesting
and insightful Debbie Millman.
How has a failure or apparent
failure set you up for later success?
Do you have a favorite
failure and quote of yours?
Oh, Tim, I have so many failures.
I think the first decade of my
career were experiments and failure,
rejection and humiliation,
but I do have a favorite,
so I will share that.
In early 2003 a good friend sent me an
email with a subject line that red begin
drinking heavily before opening the
email contained a link to a blog titled
Speak Up.
The first ever online forum about
graphic design and branding in the world
suddenly sprawled before my eyes.
I found myself reading an article
that disparaged my entire career.
This particular incident in tandem with
a number of historical rejections and
setbacks and humiliations sent me into
a really deep depression and I seriously
considered leaving the design
profession altogether. However,
however,
in the 14 years since this occurred,
this utter takedown of everything I'd
done to date and everything I thought was
a complete and total failure for a long,
long time ultimately transformed into
the foundation of everything I've done
since.
Everything I am doing now contains
the seeds of origin from that time.
So it turns out for me the
worst professional experience
I've faced ultimately
became the most important
defining experience of my life.
What is one of the best or most
worthwhile investments you've ever made?
This answer might
surprise you or maybe not,
but the best investment I've
ever made was in psychotherapy.
When I first started,
I was in my early thirties and
the bills practically killed me,
but I knew I needed to deeply understand
all the destructive things that had
happened to me in order to try to live
a remarkable life despite these things,
and I wanted this more than
anything over the years,
I still sometimes smart at the moon,
at the monthly invoices,
but I've never doubted that
this investment has profoundly,
profoundly shaped who I've become.
And although I still think
I have a lot of work to do,
it's changed and then saved my
life in every imaginable way.
And I'm in what is called psychoanalytic
psychotherapy. Put another way,
psycho analysis with an
emphasis on self psychology.
And so for me talk therapies,
the only thing that I've ever really felt
drawn to things like EMDR and behavior
modification might be really,
really helpful for other people,
but they seem a little
bit to Voodoo for me.
So some things that I think are
important to consider strictly from my
perspective,
I'm not an expert at assessing or
analyzing the value or worth of psycho
analysis only I am able to
convey what this has done for me.
Um, but for, for me, once a week therapy
did not work well twice and more,
it gives you a continuity
and an opportunity to
germinate in a way that once a
week doesn't. Also, once a week
almost feels like a catch up.
You sort of bring the therapist up to
speed on what happened in the last week
and then you have 20 minutes to sort of
talk about what's happening right now.
Sarah B takes time.
I often say that anything worthwhile
takes a long time and therapy is one of
those things. I've been in therapy
for a really long time for decades,
but I can now after those decades actually
point to empirical evidence of how my
behavior in the world by my sense of
who I am has fundamentally fundamentally
changed.
And so being in therapy and being
therapy for any length of time,
it takes dedication. It takes
stamina, it takes resilience,
persistence and a lot of courage to face
things that you might be really afraid
to look at. So it's not a
quick fix but, but like I said,
it's really saved my life.
Try and tell your therapist everything.
If you edit who you are or if you pretend
to be something that you're not in
order to impress the therapist.
If you want to project who
were how you want to be seen,
it will take that much longer.
So just be yourself.
They've likely in their practice,
heard everything.
They understand humanity.
So just be yourself.
If you're afraid your
therapist will judge you.
Tell them that also because that
whole projection is really critical to
understanding the dynamic that
you have with people in general.
So all of these things are
really important to talk about.
There is no shame in feeling shame.
And I'm saying this from
a place of deep empathy.
Almost everyone feels shame.
I think Bernay Brown says that anybody
that doesn't feel shame is likely, um,
a pathological person.
So almost everyone does in therapy
will help you understand it.
There was nothing like understanding
your motivations and insecurities to help
you integrate all of those feelings
in your psyche in the most healthy and
authentic way.
So for me,
I would not recommend going to a
therapist that one of your friends goes to
asking your friends for,
for all,
and then going to somebody that they
see might seem like a good idea because
that person trusts them.
And therefore by extension you
might feel like you can too.
But it ends up blurring things.
Um,
quite a bit.
And I think most therapists abide by
this rule now of not seeing friends of,
or clients of, of friends. Um,
things really do get very blurry and
boundaries can get weird and I just don't
recommend that. Okay, big
elephant in the room here.
It is going to be expensive.
But what is more valuable than
better understanding who you are,
breaking intrinsic bad habits,
getting over much of your shit or at
least understanding why you do the shit in
the first place and generally
living a happier, more contented,
more peaceful life. One thing that
I've come to understand recently,
and this was actually not only through
the help of my therapist and guidance
from my therapist,
but also through my dear,
dear friend Seth Goden is understanding
the difference between happiness and
pleasure.
And I think people are often trying to
reach for and strive for pleasure and,
and the response to trying to seek
pleasure is actually wanting more pleasure
after that. You know, we live
on this hedonistic treadmill,
we metabolize our purchases
and our experiences very
quickly and so when we have
that pleasure or experience that pleasure,
then we want more.
Happiness is very different. Happiness
essentially means you're okay as is.
You don't need more, you don't want
more, you feel good with what you have.
And I think that therapy really helps you
understand the difference between what
you see,
what your motivations are,
and ultimately what you want and how
you can manifest that in your life.
So breaking these intrinsic bad habits,
getting over much of your
shit and generally living
this happier, more contented,
more peaceful life is something that I
think is the ultimate gift of therapy or
the payoff. And, and Leslie,
my advice to anyone looking for a
therapist is to make sure they're really
trained eye.
I highly recommend training here,
a phd and MD plus postdoctoral training.
You really do get what you pay for here
and I highly recommend somebody that is
truly fully educated in what they do.
What are bad recommendations you hear
in your profession or area of expertise?
I don't believe in work life balance.
I believe if you view
your work as a calling,
it is a labor of love rather than
laborious. When your work is a calling,
you're not approaching the amount of hours
you were working with with this sense
of dread or counting the minutes until
the weekend you're calling can become a
life affirming engagement that can
provide its own balance and spiritual
nourishment and ironically,
it takes hard work to achieve this.
So when you were in your 20s and your
thirties and you want to have a remarkable
fulfilling career,
you must work hard.
If you don't work harder than everyone
else, you will not get ahead. Also,
if you're looking for work life balance
in your 20s or 30s you're likely in the
wrong career.
If you're doing something that you love,
you don't want work life balance,
you want to be able to do this thing
that you love is often as possible.
Our guest today is Neil Strauss.
You
can
find
him on
twitter@neilstraussinstagramatneal_straussandneilstrauss.com
he is an eight time New York
Times bestselling author.
He is a glutton for punishment,
likes to write a lot of books,
his books,
the game and rules of the game for which
he went undercover in a secret society
of pickup artists,
made him an international celebrity in
an accidental hero to men around the
world and his followup book,
the truth,
subtitle and uncomfortable
book about relationships.
Strauss dives deep into the worlds
of sex addiction, non monogamy,
infidelity and intimacy and explores
the hidden forces that caused people to
choose each other,
stay together and break up.
He most recently
coauthored with Kevin Hart,
the instant Number One New York Times
bestseller. I can't make this up.
Life lessons.
How has a failure or apparent
failure set you up for later success?
Do you have any favorite failure of yours?
And it's funny, like it's
such a theme, right? Like,
like those failures
might hurt at the time,
but I think anyone who's got anywhere say
those failures are the best thing that
ever happened to them.
I mean for me,
and it's kind of embarrassing because I
ended up writing for the New York Times
for 10 years, is I was actually
rejected from journalism school. Right.
What's the lesson there is like
if you're rejected from something,
it doesn't mean it's not right for you.
It just means it wasn't right for the
person who made that decision. And,
and especially if you're doing
something new or difference, uh,
and you're trying to go
somewhere that's very status quo,
they're not going to get your except you.
So it's a powerful thing and not a lot
of people have this inner confidence to
know this is my passion and I don't
need someone to give me a green light to
live in my passion. So, so, uh,
so I got rejected from journalism
school and I think if I got accepted,
I would have followed the regular routes
and like been covering like city hall
meetings and like, you know,
Weehawken New Jersey or something.
And no offense to anyone,
everything. Weehawken uh, yeah.
So not getting into journalism school
was the only reason I became a journalist
and wrote for the New York
Times. Uh, and often right there,
there's other paths to
get to where you want.
And sometimes you have to trust that
the path you're on is the right path.
In fact, you have to trust it
because there's no other path,
but the one you're on. And
the bigger idea is this, uh,
the outcome is not the outcome.
And what I mean by this is
there's that as the famous,
I want to say it says
Zen parable and it's a,
and I'm going to totally
misquote it and get it wrong,
but there's a farmer and uh,
his horse breaks its brakes.
Uh, uh, his horse, I
dunno, as horse runs away,
let's say horse runs away and to
say, that's too bad. I'm sorry,
your horse ran away. It's really gonna
mess up your farm. He's like, Nah,
it's all right. You
know, you know, I'd be,
don't know yet if it's for the good or
for the bad. And then maybe his horse,
I think it's worse, came back with
like four other horses. And again,
I'm totally massacring this parable,
but you'll get the point.
His horse came back with four other horses
and they're like, wow, that's amazing.
Now you have horses. How lucky are you?
He's like, well, I dunno. We'll see.
Then one day his son is riding the
horse. Uh, one of the new horses,
the Horse Buxom the son, his throne, and
he breaks his, you're like, you know,
really bad. They shatters and breaks his
leg. And they said, oh, that's too bad.
I'm sorry, your son break your leg, broke
his leg. That's horrible for you and him.
And now he can't work on the farm and
all these bad things. And the pharmacist,
I don't know, you know, we'll see.
I don't know if it's bad or good.
Then there's suddenly a war and they go
to kind of draft people into the war.
And uh,
turns out the son can't go off to fight
because he's broken his leg and his life
was saved because he's broke
his leg. I said, oh my God,
thank God that horse three year son, now
he was likely saved. And the farmer says,
I don't know.
We'll see.
And the point is you don't
know if something's good
or bad because he only one
handing right.
And even at any of the university goes
on in your family and your loved ones,
they go on to. So the outcomes, not
the outcome. The end is not the end.
We measure these things by
these end points that are
not the real end points for
the truth is you don't know,
you'll see keep moving forward.
You don't know the outcome
is not the outcome.
What is one of the best or most
worthwhile investments you've ever made?
I would just say that for me it was time.
Time is obviously the most valuable
resource we have. Side note,
and this is something that's
often talked about here,
is just people are so careful with their
money even with getting ripped off or a
dollar, $3, $5, yet they're so, uh, um,
generous with their time. In
fact, I shouldn't even meet
you with this right now.
I got things to do.
A little exercise that I learned from
a marketer named Dan Kennedy is a,
there's kind of a form that you can do,
which is figure out what
you make in a year, uh,
um,
divided by the amount of work hours in
a year and then divide that by three
cause the average person only
spends one third of each workout.
We're working and that's
what your time is worth.
It's the next time you feel like an
obligation to go to lunch with someone,
you know,
add,
add up and see if you really want to be
giving that person however many dollars
that is.
So the point is,
the best events and I made was actually
an investment of time, which was,
I was an unpaid intern at the village
voice. And I think like the secrets and,
and again, Robert Greene says
this in his book mastery.
It's something that's often said,
but like being willing to work.
And this goes against everything in the
culture right now and a lot of ways,
but really being willing to work for
free and to be totally exploited.
Uh, he is as a resource. Um,
just to be around people who are writing
around people who are creative in Sida,
sort of busy a newspaper newsroom
that was full of, you know,
culture and life and to be around
artists and critics and writers.
I really admire that,
like changed my life.
If I was not an unpaid intern at the
village voice and got rejected from
journalism school, again I wouldn't
be writing and talking to you.
I literally spent a year just opening
mail and doing people's expense reports
and waiting for the chance
just to write like once.
But the crazy thing is once I wrote once,
no one knew I was an intern.
They just thought it was a writer for the
village voice. And that got me really,
uh, you know, really far. I think I
stayed there for four years. I think they,
it was really hard for them to get
rid of me was so, uh, so that, that,
that actually was my,
my journalism school and I only learned
to write by having great editors.
So I would say like being willing to
listen to someone who is a more proficient
at you.
Then something telling you what you're
doing wrong and internalizing that and
not taking it personally is, is
huge. Are they always right? No,
but they might know more than he is. So
it's worth seriously considering. Um,
I've seen amazing people who
are just starting something new,
who let their ego get in the way
of a good lesson or opportunity.
I've sat there why maybe the greatest
surfer in the world is giving an amateur
surfer advice and amateur surfer is so
worried that there'll be judged by the
famous guy.
Did they try to pretend when they think
they know what they're talking about and
what they know about surfing
instead of just shutting up,
listening and trying it.
Um, and here's what I,
here's another thing about
everybody who's great.
I can go off on these questions forever,
but another thing,
but everybody who's great is
even if they don't agree with it,
they're willing to try it if it won't
hurt them or someone else. So again,
if we talk about certificate,
adjust your stance for me with writing,
I remember my editor saying,
brush off the academic dust.
I would like to quote French postmodernism
to like show people I was smarter or
something. I don't know what I was
thinking, but try it first. Seriously,
try it and see if it works
before you discard it.
The big idea that's going to change
your life are going to change your
creativity is the one you disagree with.
If you have the resistance
to it and you try it anyway,
that's where the big breakthrough is.
The ones you agree with,
you're already doing or believing so
there won't be a big breakthrough there.
Today's guest is Scott Belsky.
You can find him on Twitter
and Instagram at Scott Belsky,
B e l s k y and@scottbelsky.com
Scott is an entrepreneur,
author and investor. He's a venture
partner at benchmark, a very, very,
very highly regarded venture
capital firm based in San Francisco.
Scott Co founded [inaudible] in 2006
and served as CEO until Adobe acquired
[inaudible] in 2012 millions of people
use bands to display their portfolios as
well as track and find top talent
across the creative industries.
He is an early investor
and advisor in Pinterest,
Uber and periscope among many
other fast growing startups.
He is a friend and one of the people
I call most often for startup end life
advice. And he's crafted a very, very,
very unique career and life for himself.
So without further ado,
please enjoy a few questions with the
ever so interesting and insightful,
Scott Belsky,
what are bad recommendations you hear
in your profession or area of expertise?
The first thing that came to my mind, uh,
was that industries are led by experts.
You know,
we idolize the experts in our industry.
We often forget that industries are often
transformed by neophytes, right? I mean,
we could,
you know,
bold transformations like Uber disrupting
transportation or airbnb disrupting
hospitality. These are all plays
that were led by outsiders.
I remember,
I remember talking to Joe Gebbia,
cofounder of Airbnb who was saying
that he didn't even know common hotel
industry terms when he had started airbnb.
He had no background of the business
and as such a concept that so many hotel
executives discounted as ridiculous that
the customer would never want, you know,
they were more open to and uh,
which begs the question, you know,
perhaps the playbook,
the change in industry,
it is to be naive enough at the start to
question these basic assumptions and to
stay alive long enough to employ skills
that are unique and advantage as to the
space that you see to change new.
Perhaps this naive excitement
and pragmatic expertise
are as equally important
traits. Uh, but just a different times.
The second bad recommendations you
hear in your profession, um, is,
uh, is that customers know
best. And the only, Gosh,
the only focus group I ever ran at the
hands was in the very beginning in 2007
when we were debating a number of
different approaches towards our mission,
which was to organize the
creative world. We presented, uh,
the focus group that we've
gathered together with a
bottle of wine. And, uh, uh,
one evening, uh, we presented it to
this focus group of participants,
five or six different ideas.
And then ask them to complete a survey
because we were really trying to
triangulate and what we would be
doing for us and our business.
Universally participants said that the
last thing that they wanted was quote
unquote, yet another social network
to connect with creative peers.
They figured that my space was
sufficient for this purpose,
but when they were asked by us
about their greatest struggles,
participants talked about, uh, you know,
the expense and efficiencies and
maintaining an online portfolio and how
difficult it was to get attribution for
the creative work that they had made.
And so we were faced with a classic
example of don't ask customers what they
want,
figure out what they need.
And we ultimately built a social network
for creative professionals that is now
the world's leading creative professional
community with over 12 million numbers.
And you know,
six years later it was acquired by Adobe.
And so there was an
important message there,
which is you do always have to be
seeking empathy with your customer.
You can't always necessarily expect them
to know what you're supposed to do for
them.
What advice would you give to a smart
driven college student about to enter the
so called real world? What advice
do you think they should ignore?
So the f I started with the fact that
they should not hold out for the perfect
job or title. Don't optimize for the
slightly higher salary, you know,
instead focus on,
I think the two things that actually
matter it early on in the career.
Number one,
every step in your early career must
get you incrementally closer to it ever
genuinely interests you.
And the most promising coffee success is
pursuing genuine interests and setting
yourself up for the
circumstantial relationships,
collaborations, experiences,
or mistakes of the eye that will
make all the difference in your life.
I like to say that a labor of love
always pays off just not how and when you
expect. So you want to say
yourself out by, uh, to succeed,
by taking new jobs and roles that you
incrementally closer to the things that
are genuinely interesting to you.
And I think we oftentimes fall into
that spotlight of seduction where we're
offered a great opportunity.
That sounds great, but um,
isn't getting us closer to an
interest in us over the long term.
And that is I think where
we get off the rails,
have a great career via
the number two is uh,
is the fact that the greatest lessons
you learned in the beginning of a career
are about people you know, how to work
with people, be managed by people,
manage expectations with people and
lead other people. And so as such,
the team you choose to join and your
boss are obviously huge factors in the
value of a professional experience
early in your career. And again,
I see so many people optimizing
for higher salary or a, uh,
you know,
cooler sending job and not actually doing
the diligence on who they're actually
going to be working for or with,
I guess today is Veronica Belmont.
You can find her on Twitter,
Instagram and Facebook at Veronica.
That's one hell of a handle and learn
about her work and her goings on projects
and so on@veronicabelmont.com Veronica
is a bot obsessed product manager in San
Francisco.
She works for robot,
helping to make sure employees get the
recognition they deserve on their teams.
She also helps to Admin Bot wiki.org and
Bot makers.org a huge community of Bot
creators and enthusiasts. As a
writer, producer, and speaker.
Her primary goal has been
to educate audiences of all
types about how technology
can enhance their lives through the years.
Her love of innovation has led to
advising many startups on product
communications and marketing,
including good reads,
which was acquired by Amazon about.me,
which was acquired by AOL daily drip,
soundtracking acquired by rap city,
milk acquired by Google. We game
acquired by tagged forge, Schick,
CEO,
and more.
She's also a podcaster and hosts Irl
Fort Mozilla and sword and laser.
So without further ado, please enjoy
the wisdom of Veronica Belmont.
How has a failure or apparent
failure set you up for later success?
Do you have a favorite failure of yours?
This one is kind of tough to talk about.
Um,
my favorite failure I guess a was hosting
the season six premiere of game of
Thrones for Hbo. Uh, it
was great outwardly. Um,
but of course I made the mistake of
going online afterwards and reading the
comments, super bad idea. Um,
I spent what should have been a really
magical evening sitting in my hotel room
sobbing into the phone with my husband.
Uh,
but with that feeling like
really came certainty,
I had been casually thinking about making
a career switch for the previous six
months or so, but I was scared of trying
to do something I had never done before
professionally. So sitting there
in that hotel room, I thought,
why am I spending my time doing something
that consistently makes me miserable?
Why not finally just take that chance?
So I did.
I stopped taking any freelance
gigs. I, I wrapped up all of my,
my video contracts and I spent all of my
time learning about product management
and, and figuring out where I
best fit in. So overall, I mean,
it was a horrible night,
but it was also the impetus for
something completely new and wonderful.
And I don't know if I would've been able
to really make that leap if I hadn't
had such a horrible experience
that particular night. I, I,
I can almost see myself just having
spent the next year waffling on that
decision. Um, so it was
nice to have that finality.
What are bad recommendations that you
hear in your profession or area of
expertise?
I think people assume that you have
to weigh all feedback on your product,
you know, whether that's a
podcast or, or an APP, whatever.
Equally,
uh,
not all feedback is created equal and not
all ideas from your users are going to
be good ones.
Uh,
taking too much stock in feedback can
really change the vision for your own
product and, and suddenly it's not
going to feel like yours anymore.
What advice would you give to a smart
driven college student about to enter the
real world?
I've given this advice so many
times throughout my career. It's,
it's kind of ridiculous,
but I think it still holds true for
almost any kind of career path or,
or project you're working on.
A,
don't wait until you get a job to do
the thing you want to be doing for most
careers.
Showing that you have initiative
by working on projects
related to your future.
Hopeful job is an amazing way to get
a foot in the door. So for example,
if you want to be a
writer or a journalist,
start keeping a blog that
you update regularly.
Something that you can show
them later that says, Hey,
I've been writing about this
topic for the past year.
Now I'm an expert in this area. If you
want to be an engineer or a programmer,
create and maintain a project on get hub.
Get hub is basically like the new resume.
Anything that you can point to on
your linkedin that is screaming, hey,
I'm passionate about this
stuff is going to work.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share
the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour workweek.com
that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you
by Athletic Greens. Every year.
Of course people look for
new ways to become healthier,
to take their fitness and so
on to the next level. For me,
step number one is having some
form of nutritional insurance.
That's how I would look at it and the
nutritional insurance needs to make sure
all of my basic needs are met,
all the boxes checked regardless of
travel schedule, missed meals and so on.
They're going to be times in the new
year when your diet and exercise will get
interrupted. Life will interrupted in
during those times. You want a safety net?
I get asked all the time, if you could
only use one supplement, what would it be?
My answer is inevitably athletic Greens.
It is your all in one
nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that,
and I travel with it
to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to
ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day.
As listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can receive 30% off of your first
order by visiting Athletic greens.com.
Forward slash to him. That is a great
deal on one of my favorite products,
and it covers my basis.
Each day is part of my routine and it
leaves me with less to worry about. If,
for instance, I have to skip a meal
or just can't get a high quality meal,
so check it out.
Go to athleticgreens.com forward slash
Tim and learn all about this episode is
brought to you by four sigmatic.
You might remember four sigmatic
for their mushroom coffee,
which was created by those clever finished
founders and when I first mentioned
that coffee on this podcast,
the product sold out in less than a week.
It lights you up like a Christmas tree,
which can be really useful. However,
recently I've been testing the opposite
side of the spectrum of new product and
that is their Reishi mushroom elixir
to help me end my day to get to sleep.
As you guys may know,
longtime listeners,
at least I struggled with insomnia for
decades. I have a largely fixed that,
but still shutting off my monkey
brain has never been easy.
It still isn't easy very
often and I found Reishi,
which had been fascinated by for
a few years now, has been very,
very effective and calming
their old formula. However,
four sigmatic old formula included
Stevia and I like to avoid sweeteners,
all sweeteners for a host of reasons,
and I then just ping them and asked,
hey guys,
I would love to experiment with
this and maybe actually suggested,
but I'd like a version without
sweeteners if you'd be open to it,
but too much of a headache,
don't worry.
And they are always game
for experimentation.
And so they created a special
custom version without the Stevia,
without sweeteners.
Now it is part of my nightly routine.
Their ratio elixir comes
in single serving packets,
which are perfect for travel and in fact
I'm about to leave the country right
now and I have a packet in front of me
that's just going to sit in the end of my
carry on bag.
You only need hot water and it mixes very,
very easily.
Here's some recommended copy
that they put in the read,
so I'm going to read it and I'll
give you my take quote, a warning.
For those in the experimental mindset,
Reishi is strong and bitter in
parentheses like any great medicine.
So if the bitterness is too much,
I recommend trying it with honey end or
nut milk such as almond milk and quote,
so I'm going to say,
no,
you should suck it up and you should drink
the tea because it's not that bitter.
And maybe should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
young ins. When they
say, well, I'm sure cool,
which means you're not able to eat
bitterness. Bitter is in many cases,
an indication of things that help
liver detoxification. It's on,
not saying that's the case here,
but I've tested this ratio
lecture on family members,
on friends. Everybody has liked
it. It's a little bit, or if the,
it's not that hard,
so I would just say suck it up and no,
don't put it in honey or nut
milk or any of that shit.
Just drink the goddamn tea. It's
delicious. I think. All right.
If you like to air and that kind of stuff,
that type of tea,
you're going to dig it. So just
try it. Okay. Back to then my read.
If you'd like to naturally improve
your sleep, both onset and quality,
I think naturally you might just
enjoy this ratio lecture without any
sweeteners. It has organic, Reishi
extract, organic fueled, mid extract,
organic rose hips extract, organic
Tulsi extract. And that's it.
No fancy stuff, no artificial watching
McCall at anything. So check it out.
Go to foursigmatic.com forward slash
and Ferris and get 20% off this special
batch. I don't know if they're gonna
be making much more of this, uh,
it since it was made specifically for
you guys to do me a favor and try it out
so that they continue to be
open to experimenting with
me to create products for
you guys. Specifically check it
out for Sigmadek. That's Fou, R, s,
I g m a t I c.com forward
slash in Ferris, F, e r r,
I s s and get 20% off this special batch.
And uh,
you must use the code Ferris to
receive a discount FTR our ISS.
So again,
going to foursigmatic.com forward slash
Ferris and then use code Ferris for 20%
off of this rare,
exclusive,
limited run of Reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines
with out any sweeteners.
Enjoy.